pas de rouge pas de blanc sur la colline
du parlement cette année mais partout du
orange à la mémoire des enfants
autochtones disparues
ils étaient des milliers à marcher en
appui au peuple autochtone guidés par
une survivante des écoles résidentielles
une solidarité qui transcende les
cultures et les générations autochtone
non autochtone jeunes moins jeunes tous
réunis pour lancer un message pour le
canada
le son des tambours arraisonné partout
au pays l'heure est au recueillement
comprendre la peine et la douleur de
tous ces parents qui n'ont jamais revu
leurs enfants d'abord au bord du
moustoir de clore un moment de réflexion
l'occasion de faire un appel à l'action
du domaine calera coach en scène le
premier ministre justin trudeau
reconnaît l'ampleur du drame
il a lui même demandé que le drapeau du
canada reste en berne
la plus grosse erreur qu'on a fait en
tant que pays ça a été l'assimilation
forcée des enfants autochtones par les
passionne qui a causé des effets
néfastes qui dure aujourd'hui pour les
leaders autochtones
il faut affronter le passé comprendre
les chapitres les plus sombres de
l'histoire tout en restant unis pour
guérir
une prise de conscience un moment
d'introspection histoire canadienne
à l'école on n'apprend pas vraiment cet
art si si c'est vraiment important si on
n'a pas le savoir on peut pas bouger
bouger changer les choses
plusieurs canadiens l'eau qui commencent
à comprendre qu'il y ait eu des
injustices et puis quand qui ont un beau
bouquin qui a quelque chose d'une plaie
ils sont la guérir sinon ça devient de
plus en plus maligne et c'est comme un
cancer
un pas de plus dans le long chemin vers
la réconciliation
alors que les adultes de demain veulent
déjà changé les choses pour qu'on se
souvienne de chaque enfant à sa vie
minable
c est le côté sroka radio canada ottawa